you know there's a reason that after
seven years fifty percent of unions
uh fall apart it has nothing to do with
infidelity most marriages can survive
that
but it has a lot to do with financial
pressure when we when they bought a
house it was for life
that's not how people think today when
they buy a house today it's for 36
months
they're going to move they're going to
raise a family whatever it is don't fall
in love with real estate now i want to
ask you a specific question on real
estate there
uh one of the ways i started well the
way i started
was uh i bought a house putting three uh
three and a half percent down as a
fixer-upper
uh my girlfriend at the time she put
half of the down payment in
and i put down half so we each put down
about uh six seven thousand dollars plus
some closing costs and that
uh and one of the things that we found
that was so beautiful about that
was we were now able to buy a
300 000 asset that needed some repairs
so i could put my own sweat equity into
it
we were able to control a 300 000 asset
having a net worth of
9 000 each uh and and so we were able to
do that with a monthly payment of about
2 000 bucks a month
and the beauty about that was worst case
scenario if we needed to
we could move and rent it out for that
you know even putting money aside for
repairs and that
uh yeah or worst case scenario we
thought hey if we can't afford the
payment we'll rent out rooms
uh isn't that potentially a way that
people can start house hacking or
renting out rooms or buy a duplex
rent out another room just to be able to
leverage up their wealth maybe
quicker than they could otherwise yes it
is and i did the same thing
with the exception that i don't think
it's a good idea with a random
girlfriend
you should enter into a financial
relationship called marriage if you're
going to do that because that asset
you become very very valuable becomes
part of the couple's
financial stability every time
i've heard of people that have and i've
got plenty of examples of this
you fall in love it's euphoric you buy a
house together you're not married
then poopoo happens fifty percent of
unions fall apart for a lot of different
reasons but then you've got this
horrific litigation trying to solve for
liquid
you know liquefying the house or one
side buys the other half
from the other it's a mess and so i
always say to people look
i did it on my own i borrowed ten
thousand dollars and i was able to buy a
house and i
rented every room out i lived in the
basement um
but i over time built a lot of equity up
in that just as you said
but i didn't do it my girlfriend at the
time because i don't even know where she
is anymore
i did it myself so unless you're getting
married
i wouldn't do it that way okay
well well fair correction there i will
say
knock on wood but lord and i uh we we
are happily married now and have two
kids
maybe we were the other 50 but i no
that's that's a great it's a great story
but i mean if
others listening i i i really you know i
wrote a book called men women and money
exactly about this and i'm very proud it
became a bestseller almost overnight but
it deals with topics like this
and it and it really talks about the
reality of you know
where money fits in love and it you know
there's a reason
that after seven years fifty percent of
unions uh fall apart it has nothing
to do with infidelity most marriages can
survive that
but it has a lot to do with financial
pressure and that's why
when i did a lot of research with
divorce lawyers and they said it's
always the money it's always the money
one couple outspends the other and drags
everybody into debt
and finally that just takes over the
only reason they're together is fighting
about
debt terrible yeah that is terrible
that's unfortunate
uh okay interesting so so a potential
way to start yeah and what we are seeing
though
uh with with home prices going up i have
this this thesis i want to run by you
i believe that potentially as home
prices continue this sort of
course that we're on lack of supply lack
of new construction
coastal cities going uh incredibly high
especially in the suburbs
if this continues at some point
investing in real estate for a normal
person becomes unaffordable
uh is it possible that america turns
into a a renter nation
where maybe the top 10 percent own
houses and ninety percent don't and they
just rent
yes but this this thesis has been tested
multiple times in the real estate market
over the last hundred years
uh prices get excessively high in
certain regions
people can't afford them they move to
other jurisdictions
it has a natural tendency to resolve
itself or the economy has explosive
growth and
salaries go up to match the cost of rent
or purchase or ownership
it tends to balance itself we're in an
extreme period right now
we've never provided 1.9 trillion
dollars of free money to the economy
ever before and we're about to maybe put
another trillion in infrastructure
spending which is going to support all
kinds of different jurisdictions
this could be the new golden age of
america and always
you know when you think about the gold
roaring 20s or the early 50s
a real estate was part of what was
coveted and still is today by every
american family
you want to own that home with the
change now that
some people particularly as we have an
older population
are preferring different kinds of
housing condominiums in where i am here
in miami have become very very popular
because of ease of use and yet their
pricing
per square foot is much more than a home
which makes no sense at all because you
don't own any real estate you just own a
box of cement
and yet yet that you know the pricing
here is four thousand five
thousand dollars a square foot for some
very premium condos
and i tracked the condo index in in
pretty well every geographic region of
the us
as a way for me to keep an eye on
inflation and housing prices
and right now we're really stretching
the limits
yeah does that mean you believe there's
a potential correction in store for real
estate
no it doesn't happen that way and again
using miami or boston as a market
or austin texas is another good market
to index
you know there's so much activity of
moving out of high tax jurisdictions
into low tax so that's why texas and
florida have this renaissance occurring
but
generally what happens first and you're
starting to see it now is
the bid ask condos are the best way to
do it because you can always index each
unit so let's say
there's one i'm looking at here i was
just examining the date on it last week
the last time it's it's a three bedroom
uh 2800 square foot condo
there's probably 30 of them in the
building that are identical and the only
difference is what floor they're on
because if you clear
obstructions you generally get a 25
premium
and so on the twilight floors where
you're half instructed it's a perfect
market in that sense
last time one of these condos traded it
traded for three million
one hundred fifty thousand the owner of
one of them now with an obstructive view
is trying to get four point six million
now that's not going to trade that's not
going to trade and it hasn't traded
and so what happens is it sits there and
i'm just now speaking about the whole
index
these condos sit on the market for
generally up to 18 months
people that put stuff on the market are
willing to wait a year and a half to see
if they can if somebody hits the bid
and if it doesn't happen the prices
start to fall so where we're at now is
we're three months into the
wait and see because the volume of
trading is slowing at that high end
which always tells me potential 20
correction coming but you just don't
know when or what the black swan event
is going to be that triggers it
because if you look at the history of of
boston miami
austin you get tremendous volatility
particularly miami there's no market
more volatile than miami
and so you know if you're if you're an
indexer like i am in in you know buying
multiple units potentially you really
want to catch it on when it starts going
down
and we haven't seen that yet so i got to
wait 12 18 months
would you be buying individual condos
as investments and then renting them out
or when yeah
absolutely absolutely for sure but you
wouldn't do it now because the economics
don't work that's another trigger
um you if you if you buy a condo
for 4.6 million then put 400 000
into it so now it's 5 million being
prepared for rental
and all you can get is 18 000 a month
which is pretty well the limit right now
um uh that's a really bad investment
and and so that that tells you that the
the unit price is overvalued it has to
come down about 30 percent
when that happens nobody knows right
right
uh now uh what about uh residential
multifamily buildings
would you just go buy a large building
or why don't you just go to austin and
buy a hundred unit building
because the cap rates are below four
percent and so um
having been in real estate my whole life
i don't buy when cap rates are sub four
percent
um when i first got involved in climate
controlled storage it was 11
cap rate now it's trading at under 5. so
you know and and i sold at a 7 cap which
meant i left 20
on the table you can't ever catch the
top or bottom but
going into real estate at sub four
percent cap rates when right when
rates potentially could rise is a very
bad outcome
and and and a real money loser so that's
why i'm just
sitting on my hands i have capital to
deploy in real estate but i haven't seen
anything that attracts me yet
you know people show me uh 3.2 cap uh
multi-family no thanks got it
yeah i've got this rule uh rule of thumb
that if interest rates go up one percent
prices come down percent almost this
this one to ten ratio
and hey if we get a two percent bump in
rates uh there there's your twenty
percent pretty quickly but then the
afford
but then it becomes unaffordable again
because the rates are higher so so how
do you balance that
well then the rental market kicks in i
mean the great thing about real estate
it does have all kinds of
pressure valve releases uh rental
becomes more attractive
remember you're what i tell people there
used to be this philosophy back in the
50s and 60s and my parents used to tell
me
when we when they bought a house it was
for life that's not how people think
today when they buy a house today it's
for 36 months
maybe five years maximum you know
whatever they're going to move they're
going to raise a family whatever it is
don't fall in love with real estate the
only argument you could make for long
term
is is waterfront property
in various regions of the world where
it's extremely hard to replace it
and so i i tend you know when i when i
purchase
waterfront property i value it based on
how many linear feet it has on that
and more you know obviously people
really covet
privacy but you look in lake tahoe or
regions of
maine or cape cod or you know nantucket
those prices have very very little um
volatility because they're based on
access to waterfront
wow and uh are you worried at all about
rising sea levels in
in florida i think what your miami beach
yeah i definitely i mean you
if you if you bought right now on the
sunset aisles of venetian causeway
another index i track
um what used to cost uh four million
just five years ago is trading for 22
million and
so when when you try and buy um
hurricane insurance you can't get it you
have to self-insure
so you know if you if you really thought
uh the ocean was going to rise 18 inches
well you'd be writing off 22 million
dollars but most people feel during
their lifetime they won't happen but
that doesn't mean it won't i mean it's
sort of a really interesting dynamic
when it rains hard in miami
here in miami beach on collins avenue it
floods by two feet
and so and then you've got to wait you
know sometimes 18 hours to get rid of
all the water it's a really interesting
dynamic of bringing up there but again
right now the markets are so buoyant
so so stretched that people are not
considering that but when you do go talk
to the insurer look i'm gonna
i'm gonna buy a 22 million dollar house
they say good luck
we're not going to insure it sure sure
it just seems like fortunately though
the hurricanes in in florida it's been
gosh it's got it's got to have been at
least 30 years since we've had a cat
5 in florida though huh it's been a
while no it has and that's exactly the
kind of thing you should say when the
cat eight comes you know
it's that's that's why do you believe
that
well i do not take anything for granted
on climate change right now i ju you
know i'm a very very big
uh i have a very big business in the
wine industry
you should be aware this morning it is
snowing
in bordeaux and the drc region and
burgundy
the loss of this crop is going to be
catastrophic
that you and we're getting hail in
geneva we're getting
freezing rain uh in the jura in
switzerland where the white wine is made
and these are this is where i source my
my juice and um we're going to get wiped
out this year that's climate change i
mean
i'm talking about snow in
you know late april in bordeaux like you
don't see that too often
do you have crop insurance there no you
can't do that
i mean it it doesn't matter because
what the challenge they're going to save
probably 18 to 20
of the crop last night we were using
water to spray on to the berries
there's all kinds of strategies you're
talking about
um you know you take take mantra shea
in in burgundy people think it's a giant
region it's the size of a parking lot
it's worth a billion dollars a row
almost it's since
it's insane and so it trades at
crazy prices lv lvmh is a corporation
buying one row of grapes at a time
so when you have that kind of an
investment you can afford you'd think to
be able to
intervene but the rules of the drc
that the multi-hundred year rules
do not allow you to do that you you you
lose your passion if you're caught
putting fertilizer up your pant leg and
walking the vines or
or or using some kind of a device to put
water on it
from your pant leg those are those are
tricks that have been tried by farmers
for hundreds of years
it's forbidden and so this is the kind
of thing you deal with in the wine
industry that tradition is why a bottle
of montriche is worth
a thousand dollars when it's a good year
and it won't be a good year in 2021.
oh yeah yeah well i'm sorry to hear that
golly yeah so climate change
i mean what do you think though but like
the federal reserve's starting to talk
about climate change
uh kathy wood kind of suggested that the
fed seems like maybe they're getting a
little distracted
and they should be focused on the
economy is is the fed right to be
concerned about climate
change to the extent there's an economic
cost i mean i think
you know if you believe that burning uh
huge amounts of coal
is detrimental and i do i mean i just
can't think that's a good thing
um you should stop buying bitcoin from
the chinese for example because that's
what they do
they they have 64 of all the coin mined
i have made a choice not to buy their
coin and frankly because institutions
have the sustainability committees to
answer to now and ethics committees and
uh they won't buy china coin
so my thesis is to start to invest in
companies that make
sustainable coin green coin yeah and i i
i ran a a this is interesting because
you're indicating it's institutions
so i asked on twitter which is mostly
going to be
retail 6486 votes here
76 percent of people who replied to my
poll
uh when i asked whether or not they care
where their bitcoin or crypto is mine
76.5 said they don't care uh and
only 10 said yes they care and they'd
even pay more
is this going to be something that
starts from institutions
and then people start caring is is that
why you're focused on that
i my experience was rather interesting i
i
first bought ethereum and bitcoin in
2017 but because i work in a highly
regulated environment
i have many investments and has some
chairman roles in certain financial
services companies
uh i have to be compliant to
institutional standards and so
uh when i announced that i had uh you
know
finally so you know regulators uh all
around the world were very negative
in 2017 on any cryptocurrencies i don't
care what country you're in
and then all of a sudden in switzerland
in germany france england australia new
zealand and canada
uh the regulator opened up in fact
there's now etfs in the canadian market
where you can buy an exchange traded
fund that only owns a bitcoin
and so i decided to increase my
weighting and went public saying that
i've reduced
my portfolio allocation for 2021 is
70 equities 22 percent
a fixed income which is a massive
reduction from a year previous
it was used to be 50 50. a 5 gold of
which half is stored and the other half
i'm balancing with gld
and then finally a three percent in
bitcoin now i didn't expect to get any
kind of feedback from that it's just a
reallocation i did it in the last weeks
of january
you got a lot of feedback oh my goodness
i was inundated with institutions
calling me from all around the world and
sovereign funds saying wait a second
where are you getting this coin you're
complying aren't you i said what do you
mean
just like 70 of those polled in your
poll i said
why would i care and they said are you
aware that 64
of this coin is coming from a country
that burns coal to make it and
has alleged human uh rights violations
and is under sanction
from the united states that's china and
i and i realized that i had
the reason these institutions are not
participating in allocating bitcoin has
nothing to do
with just the regulator although they do
consider it but regulators are opening
up
what they're concerned about is their
ethics committees and their
their sustainability committees that sit
above the investment committee
on a large institutional mandate so
before they can allocate any asset
class any asset class point of origin of
of the asset where it jurisdiction is
how it was created
these are all questions that have to get
approved by their committees
and so what i found occurred was i
immediately
said okay i'm not going to buy a blood
coin from china
what i'll do is i will go to the mining
community the pools in europe and the
pools in the u.s
and i will basically fund their
expansion i can
you know if they're looking for 20
million dollars to expand
uh facilities and become more productive
i can help them
finance that and in exchange i want a
royalty paid in virgin coin where i know
the providence
and i found a tremendous amount of
institutional interest in that
uh to join me you know beside me doing
it
it solves their problem too because they
can go to their committee say this coin
i own in a wallet that has never traded
it's it's our
coin it's property it's virgin it's
compliant it's sustainable
there are no ethics issues with it and i
believe over time
as institutions start to really get
involved in crypto
that you will see a premium you'll have
the discounted blood coin from china
and you'll have the premium virgin coin
with providence no different than blood
diamonds same thing
sure sure now is this something
that look as an example delta airlines
they have a partnership i believe it's
delta with with gevo to supply a certain
amount of
their fuel uh with biofuels i think it's
enough for like a hundred flights a year
it's a drop in the bucket right
but i feel like they do it so they can
market and and give the little green
badge hey
sometimes we use biofuels right is that
going to be the same thing i mean
is it just something where you put a
little bit in your portfolio that's
clean and the rest is whatever
because whatever then you can put the
little green check mark on
yeah i know what you're saying i mean
for years companies would do that
sort of um to get the the aura
of sustainability and that they cared
and they were green it was a marketing
stunt
but that is not what's occurring uh
today in terms of the consumer
they smell [ __ ] a mile away because
they have the power of social media to
vet out anything
and they do that and so what i'm finding
now in my own investment philosophy let
me give you an example
here's a company that i'm in a joint
venture with comcast in
this is called blue land their mission
very simple mission statement
is to eliminate 50 million plastic
bottles out of the environment a year
globally
very simple i haven't found anybody that
doesn't think that's a good idea
and so when i was pitched they said we
have found a way
to crystallize cleaning fluids a
patented way this is a
this is a full bottle of surface cleaner
toilet cleaner
they give you a sustainable bottle they
ship it to you direct
you drop this into the bottle with water
and now you've got a full month's supply
of surface cleaner
and no plastic bottle throw out now i
would have thought that company would
have a hard time
growing it is one of my most successful
companies why because
the constituency the buying constituency
doesn't want marketing [ __ ]
they want a real solution and this
company has a mission a real solution
and it works
and so that's become part of the metric
of what those consumers are buying
is it sustainable that's part of my
mandate that's what i want i'll support
this company i'll go out of my way to
support the company
i'll buy direct from them and uh it's
it's it's you know the growth rates on
this thing are going through the roof
it'll
it'll it'll hit 100 million dollars in
sales very soon
and so back it uh it could be spec but
frankly i'm not a big fan of spax
i i feel i feel it'll be bought by a
strategic
that's what will happen when you get to
100 million in sales
you you get the big guys knocking on
your door yeah
and that makes a lot of sense uh you get
like a clorox or something to come buy
that product from you
and uh patent it or well i'm sure it's
already patented by your ip
why um why no not a fan of spax is it
just because of loose
sec regulation and those uh those
ridiculous investor presentations that
are
mythical projections that they give well
no actually i do have about 20 specs in
my portfolio right now but
but only from from operators that i know
you know the spac is no different than
private equity and so i need to know the
team that's actually backing the spac
has actually done deals before and knows
how to buy at the right multiple and
knows how to operate
and so if you know you're talking about
the gore's brothers or you're talking
about
bill ackman or you're talking about
teams like that i buy their specs and i
own them right up to when they despect
then i then i look at what they've
bought and say
i look at it as a public company in fact
my wine business is in the middle of a
spa conversion right now and so
you know obviously i i'm i'm very
excited about it now we're going to go
public that way through us back so i'm
not against specs i'm against
celebrities facts the id the idea that
some
celebrity knows what they're doing in
private equity i think is a joke
i mean you have to spend your career
learning how to do that stuff
so you know sticking some celebrity on
its back and saying you know give me 250
million dollars another 500 million
dollar pipe
i avoid those like the plague i think
those are going to go to zero
wow wow go to zero oh my goodness uh
you mentioned the gorez brothers are you
in matterport
no what gore brothers i got to know uh
way back you know 20 years ago
i have a tremendous amount of respect
for their philosophy and how they
operate
and some of the people that used to work
for me did go and work for gore's and
said nothing but good things about them
i like alec i really do you know why
because he's a cash flow guy
i'm a cash flow guy he respects cash
flow
that's what he understands he
understands cash flow he doesn't
understand
future cash flow he understands cash
flow
now and then he tries to grow it he
doesn't
price businesses off maybe they'll be
profitable
maybe they'll have cash flow he looks at
existing cash flow on the stability of
that cash flow and he makes economic and
leveraged decisions based on what he
knows
is factual and his historic data from
that's the kind of operator i like to
invest
in or beside and you know it's just a
philosophy but
you know his track record is impeccable
that's great well i mean that's great to
hear yeah
a lot of us uh watching right now we uh
we're in uh one of the gore's specs uh
and it's the matterport 3d scanning
business for real estate
yeah 3d scans so
you mentioned that you're you're heavier
on cash now than than you've been
how heavy is is heavy well it's
primarily because of the reduction from
31 to 8 percent on commercial real
estate and you know that that that
started last a year ago january and then
we did do some selling during the
pandemic period march april may
at more depressed prices well right now
the cash is about
38 38 we just looked at it this morning
which is extremely high
it's extremely high and so we we are
deploying
uh we have uh done some deals uh they're
mostly private
um you know i have and i and i
also uh uh stepped up
and when i did the reallocation down
from 50 down to 22
in fixed income we did deploy into large
cap equities
but you know that's a big dislocation
when you take an asset class from 31
down
to eight i mean it's going to take me a
year or two to get put that money back
to work
and and um you know yeah that's why they
call it work i mean you know we look at
it and say we're getting zero for it
when i say cash i mean cash
i don't put it in mutual funds you know
or
short-term bond funds i mean cash cash
is cash
so if there's some kind of correction or
or illiquidity event
where these mutual funds break a buck i
won't be part of that so i
my cash makes nothing there there is
some interesting
work i'm doing with my team in crypto
where we're garnering for yield
using various leverages uh usd versus
ethereum versus
um bitcoin but this requires a
tremendous amount of
technical skill and uh uh it's more of a
corporate uh strategy and it's not
something i would recommend to people at
home
uh but i you know i have a full-time
team doing this and you can kind of
glean depending on the volatility of
bitcoin which has been less volatile
lately somewhere between five and seven
percent returns but you are taking risk
it's not free and so
i've struggled with this so i've uh i i
did a video maybe about three weeks ago
and i've talked to a few crypto
ceos block five voyager and so on uh
about
the crypto lending space and
specifically the lending of
stable coins like the gemini coin or the
usdc
my concern is it and i would love your
comment on this obviously
my concern is you've got thousands of
retail crypto investors out there who
look and go yeah i've got this stable
coin
and they see that as a savings account
uh they see that as
their cash but they don't realize
they've turned on lending so now they're
getting paid
six to eight percent on this stable coin
and so when push comes to shove and
something breaks in the crypto space
one day people go back to okay well who
gets that original dollar that's sitting
in the bank vault somewhere
well you're 13 per people down the road
because this
same dollar has been rehypothecated 13
times
isn't that a massive risk that there
could be a a lending
disaster that comes out of that
yes um it would be a illiquidity event
if you're going to do this um and i do
some i have employed a material amount
of money into this strategy
just to you know use cash but i
understand the risks i i understand the
allocation i'm taking
it is no better than a single c credit
you would never get a
triple b credit on this strategy and yet
there's room in a portfolio like mine to
have a single c
exposure for yields of five to seven
percent but what i would recommend is
and i don't have an equity interest in
them but there's a company called
circle out there that has some of the
and i've i talked to all of them
um i've got a whole team talking to
everybody that participates in this on a
corporate level so if i have a
an operating company uh which i do with
a lot of cash on this balance sheet
i can go to a circle and say look i want
to open a corporate account and decide
that maybe i'll put a five percent
allocation
into that lending strategy with full
transparency full tax reporting full
compliance
and have my cfo work with them and
that's what we've done and so
it's sort of it because all of these
wallets and all of these retail uh you
know
apps and all that stuff they're just
laden with ridiculous fees and so
when you're you know you pay us a really
stupid price to have a
i'm not going to mention names but
anything you download on your phone
you're
in the crypto space you're going to get
whacked with a ton of fees you don't see
sometimes or at least
you're not aware of and so my attitude
is if we're going to do corporate
lending
let's set up corporate lending let's go
find providers let's find
you know check out their compliance
committees let's talk to their
management
you know it's i'm very fortunate it's
it's really great to be mr wonderful
everybody returns my calls and i'm very
appreciative of that
but you know at the same time i'm doing
a lot of work for other lps
that that may want to pursue this and if
i go set it up and it works and i've
you know i've got some very smart guys
working for me on this
i'm willing to deploy some capital some
capital
uh because i believe the regulator will
continue to examine the potential of
cryptocurrencies
for for an efficient a way to run an
economy
and if we don't do it the chinese will
and i'd be very very careful you know
that that we stay as i like to say oh
could ant
with what the chinese are doing on
cryptocurrencies they would love nothing
more than to create a coin
controlled by their own blockchain
that they could basically provide a
stable coin to the world to trade of
like the american dollar is
and then turn it off if some you say
something bad about china
they could do that and i don't want to
see them do that so where
as i said earlier an economic war with
them if any and if anybody's going to ge
you know create a stabilized coin for
global commerce
i want it to be the united states and
have the same rule of law associated
with it
and the same court system associated
with it and then because for me who does
business in switzerland in europe in
in england in australia with all these
different currencies i get killed
when i'm transferring into euro or or
swiss francs or british pounds
what a total pain in the butt why can't
i just use a standardized currency and
trade in all those countries
right right that completely makes sense
now you mentioned that this is single c
i mean isn't that like
you're talking junk level but these are
stable coins
it's not rated and so it's not even fair
to call it single c
it is what it is it's exactly as you
described there are inherent risks
that most people do not understand and
so
when you get into um you know it's
it's it's like that song superstition
you know
when you trade in things you don't
understand
that's what happens bad things happen
sometimes if you like that video
where did you see my next one don't
forget to click right over here
and subscribe